هذا وقد افادت مراسله الجزيره ان لقاء
نتنياهو مع جزء من عائله الاسرى
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في غزه قد بدا
ونقلت صحيفه اسرائيل اليوم عن الرئيس
الاسرائيلي انه اكد استعداد اسرائيل
لهدني اخرى من اجل السماح بالافراج عن
الاسرى من جانبه نقل موقع اكسيوس ان
نتنياهو ووزير دفاعه يوف جالانت ابلغ وزير
الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستون ان اسرائيل
مستعده لمنح الدبلوماسيه فرصه شرط حدوث
تقدم خلال
اسابيع وينضم الينا من الناصره محمود يزبك
الخبير بالشؤون الاسرائيليه اهلا بك دكتور
محمود يزبك برايك هل فعلا مازال هناك مجال
للدبلوماسي في هذه
الحرب لا مجال
امام اسرائيل في الوضع الحالي على الرغم
من كل الضربات المؤلمه التي توجهها لغزه
ونرى امام اينها قتلى من استشهاد الاطفال
الرضع لا مجال امام اسرائيل بعد هذا الفشل
الذي ما دام 74 يوم حتى الان الا ان تعطي
فرصه للدبلوماسي ولذلك على الرغم من يعني
من موقف نتنياهو المتشدد اعلاميا يعني يجب
ان نفرق ما بين الاعلام لانه يريد ان يظهر
امام الاسرائيليين وكانه البطل بعد ان فشل
هذا الفشل الذريع وما بين ما يجري في
الغرف المغلقه قبل اسبوع نتنياهو اعلن
وبشكل واضح انه لن يرسل رئيس المساد
للاجتماع مع اي من القطريين او المصريين
او غيرهم وبعد يومين من حادثه مقتل الاسرى
الاسرائيليين في في
غزه الضغط الشارع الاسرائيلي تزايد على
نتنياهو وتراجع مباشره ومن ثم تم ار سال
رئيس المساد الاسرائيلي اللي يجتمع برئيس
الوزراء القطري ورئيس السي اي ايه في في
في وارش تم الاضط شعبي اذا هل تتوقع ان
يزيد هذا الضغط دكتور يزبك ايه عندما نعلم
ما نقلته القناه الاسرائيليه الثاني عش من
ان عددا من المدنيين الاسرائيليين قتلتهم
اسرائيل نفسها بنيران اسرائيليه بدبابه ق
صفتهم وايضا بالطيران
نعم يعني الضغط هذه الحرب حتى الان حقيقه
انه يعني الغالبيه العظمى مع من الشارع
الاسرائيلي هي صامته او تؤيد بصمت هذه
الحرب لكن في هنالك قضيه اساسيه مطروحه
على الساحه وهي قضيه الاسرى الاسرائيليين
وعائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين هي عائلات
فعاله وفاعله جدا على الشارع الاسرائيل
وفي الشارع يعني الشارع تتظاهر في الشارع
وم كل وهذه العائلات بدا بدات تستقطب ليس
فقط تعاطفا انما تاييدا حقيقيا يعني الشيء
الجديد الذي كان خلال الايام السابقه كان
انه
انضمام عائلات قتلى اسرائيليين فقدوا
ابنائهم في هذه الحرب او في حروب سابقه
انضموا الى هؤلاء المتظاهرين امام وزاره
الدفاع الاسرائيليه في تل ابيب ومما اضطر
نتنياهو بعد ان رفض مرات عده ان يلتقي ب
بممثلين عائلات الاسرى ان يقوم بلقائهم
هذه الليله مثل ما سمعنا في الساعه
السادسه مساء معنى ذلك انه نتنياهو طبعا
يعرف وفهم انه الضغط ضغط الشارع ق يولد
خساره له في صندوق الانتخابات وهذا الشخص
كما نعرفه جيدا اهم شيء بالنسبه له هو
نفسه ولا يريد ان يخسر يعني تاييدا
مستقبليا فهو يقوم بهذا الاجتماع اليوم مع
عائلات الاسرى ليكون لهم عمليا يعني انه
انه بدات المفاوضات
ويطمئنهم انه هو يفعل كل ما يستطيع من اجل
الافراج
عن الاسر الاسرائيليين وهذا كان فقط نتيجه
لضغط يعني من الشارع الاسرائيلي عليه وليس
من حسن اخلاقه او يعني
من لانه هو يعني في موقف قوه على العكس
تماما هو يشعر انه هو وحكومته في موقف ضعف
وسبب موقف الضعف هذا مثل ما قلت انه 74
يوم من الحرب على غزه والدمار الهائل الذي
يحصل في غزه وقتل الاطفال يعني حوالي
20,000 انسان تم قتلهم و 70% من هؤلاء
القتل هم من النساء والاطفال يعني ل حينما
نقول اطفال انا اقصد فيهم قسم كبير من
هؤلاء هم رضع ليس فقط اطفال يعني بعمر 10
سنوات او تسع سنوات انما الرضع كذلك
والعالم يشهد ذلك وبدا العالم يتغير وحتى
حتى الرئيس الامريكي يشعر بانه يخسر من
بعد ان قام بتاييد اسرائيل تاييدا مطلقا
مما خلك ضغطا جديدا وزياره اوستن التي
كانت مع رئيس اركانه قبل يوم في تل ابيب
هي لم تكن زياره من اجل يعني انه يشرب
القهوه هو رئيس الاركان الامريكي في
اسرائيل طبعا هنالك ضغط امريكي يريد ان
يفهموا الى اين تذهب هذه الحرب لان هذه
الحرب لا تستطيع ان تحقق شيء مثل ما يحصل
حتى الان وهذا ولد مواقف جديده لد نتنياهو
وهذا الموقف
بداه اليوم باجتماعه مع عائلا الا
الاسرائيليين نعم شكرا جزيلا دكتور محمود
يزبك الخبير بشون الاسرائيليه كنت معنا من
الناصره شكرا لك